innovation happens and it happens now in
ways that are almost instant in the
marketplace so somebody comes up with a
wonderful idea that we could do a 3d
printer in the old days it might Bend 12
years before we could see it but about
nine months later for twelve hundred
dollars you can buy one or a drone now
not a missile firing drone but a drone
with a high pro now 4k camera that you
can fly above your house or above a
crowd and get a video or even
increasingly wearables and the like what
we do at the Maisie centers we take a
innovation that's cool cool cool and ask
an interesting very important question
beyond being cool can it do anything
specifically can it help an individual
or corporation with learning and so
drones they're kind of fun to fly I have
three of them but if you worked at an
insurance company and there was a fire
imagine the ability to literally hours
after the fire is under control to fly
above not only for you as the insurance
company doing in audit but think about
the peace of mind for the owner of that
house so we're always involved kind of
like the MIT Media Lab for learning to
look at the connection between
technology and innovation and learning
you